Michael Kay the Yankee announcer might
be territorial here with this but
Michael thanks for joining us let me
start there can you look at this
objectively and say who's been more
valuable to their franchise 40
absolutely not good okay I thought about
it this way you know because I've been
watching the show and and I think that
they both have been equally important on
the field but if you really want a
tiebreaker on it the Red Sox desperately
needed a world championship they had not
won one since 1918 so the Yankees had 22
championships before Derek's first so he
had five and Ortiz at three but the
three that the Red Sox had were so much
more needed than the five that the
Yankees got that Ortiz played a big role
in them so if you need a tiebreaker I
guess Ortiz is more valuable in that
sense because the red sauce was so
desperate to break that curse i
mentioned that Jeter during the regular
season and playing shortstop you know
being in the field everything that he
did the intangibles it's just I was
trying to think of somebody more
dangerous at the plate the [ __ ] in
the last 15 years than David Ortiz do
you have somebody probably not uh he I
think he's the reason that he pinned
that you know losing the 30 lead on the
Yankees in 2004 I think he was the main
reason for that he and Dave Roberts
Roberts steel but you know gia was a
really good postseason hit or two but
you know Ortiz got big big hits and I
think you know what you just said before
I came on I don't think they win those
three championships without Ortiz I'm
not sure that the Yankees went five
without Jeter but can you plug in just
say an average shortstop and the Yankees
win some of those championships maybe
but not five I'm not sure you could plug
in another designated hitter with David
Ortiz and have them win those titles I
was listening to your show yesterday and
you were talking about that Yankee fans
and do you honor David Ortiz what what
would be the right way for you if you're
looking at this is a Yankee fan to honor
the enemy and David Ortiz in the words
of Ted Cruz you know you have to vote
your conscience
not sure what their conscience is I mean
this guy is tormented them but in New
York I don't think we're as tough of
fans as we've been made out to be
because Nick fans gave you know Michael
Jordan standing ovation and he
personally kept them from winning
championships over those years I think
they'll probably cheer him in the first
inning on Thursday and then they'll boom
after that I'm kind of shocked that the
Yankees are having a ceremony for I just
I don't know Dan maybe you do when this
whole retirement tour started with
everybody I look at Jeter and I look at
Rivera and Ripken and Kobe and those are
iconic players and although David Ortiz
is a superstar I don't know if I'd make
him iconic but it seems like everybody
is doing these retirement to her so if
the Yankees didn't do it they look bad
so that's number one said the Yankees
would give them a ceremony on thursday i
think the Yankee fans will it'll be like
it was yesterday it'll be a smattering
of cheers & boos but i think that the
respect will probably went out you're
also looking at this and i think you
know what i'll celebrate you you did
beat us and we're bigger than everybody
else where the Yankees we can
acknowledge greatness because we know
greatness and plus you're getting rid of
Big Papi that would be reason enough to
celebrate and applaud to say yes thank
you now please leave us alone you know
what I hear what you're saying and
that's probably going to be the way it
goes but I'm so difficult and bad a guy
to ask this because I mean you've known
me for a long time I am a low-road guy
hit the low road because i think the
high road is the road more traveled i'd
rather take the low road but I'm not the
guy that's going to be sitting in the
stands but young Michael Kay is a Yankee
fan is a 15 16 year-old I probably would
not give a standing ovation at most
because my parents raised me the right
way I probably wouldn't make a sound
he's Michael Kay the Yankee broadcaster
joining us Dan Patrick show recap what
happened yesterday during the engagement
and how much of a heads up were you
given that this was going to happen no
there was zero heads up between innings
I'm staring up at the scoreboard
absent-mindedly and I see that all look
there's another guy asking a woman to
marry him on the scoreboard and then I
saw this look of abject
horror on the kids face and you can see
he'd lost the ring so then I alerted our
truck and they found exactly where it
was and then we just started following
it between pitches so we didn't have any
kind of a tip-off at all and all I could
think of is when I got engaged I got
engaged at night on the beach and I
started to think if I drop this ring I'm
just gonna lie there on the sand until
the Sun comes up because I mean that's
everybody's worst nightmare and now it's
playing out in front of 35,000 people on
the whole section got engaged as well no
pun intended and then they finally found
it in the cuff of her jeans and the kid
you know was interviewed by meredith
marakovits on yes and he said I started
crying I mean that's pretty emotional
stuff I mean getting getting engaged as
emotional in itself and then you lose
the ring pretty amazing what's the
oddest thing you've ever called
play-by-play was whoo boy I don't know
that's a tough question well I did I did
broadcast you know during the stop
earlier so that was pretty odd well I'm
sure you've seen a lot of things in the
stands at Yankee Stadium some things
that you do can do play-by-play on and
some that you probably can and as you
know we see things that don't go out
over the air you know and those are very
odd but I think that that's decreased
more as the stadium gets more fill but
back in the early 90s when it was empty
I mean there were yeah there's things
going on the upper deck and some
stadiums that you just can't show uh one
baseball item here we had Brian in and
he talked about sort of this seismic
shift here you know Cashman talked about
bringing up younger guys and you have
some you know contracts that are pretty
pretty heavy get rid of those but Gary
Sanchez and I know that they paid him
well but Gary Sanchez his kind of gone
above and beyond what I guess the
Yankees thought he would would do here
well I think he's gone above and beyond
what anybody's ever done other than
wally burger so he's 20 home runs
fastest in baseball he and burger I
don't I don't think they could have even
imagined in their best case scenario
that he'd be this good and it shows you
how how tough it is to gauge
baseball players Dan he couldn't beat
out Austin Romine in spring training for
the backup job and that turns out to be
better for him because if he had been
the backup catcher we never would have
had an opportunity to see him play every
single day and I think then toward the
middle of the euro and maybe they
thought that he was ready to come up the
thing that was holding him up with the
a-rod situation because you have that
you know Brian McCann deserved to play
somewhere as well and the Yankees had a
tiptoe around the a-rod stuff so once a
rod was released and that freed them up
to bring up Gary Sanchez he's been
unbelievable and you know they have got
all these prospects in the top system
and the bottom line is if you could get
one out of 10 prospects to make it as
big as Gary Sanchez you've hit a home
run so this is the guy they could build
around that's how good he's been but if
you look at this team now are we looking
back to sort of the embryonic stages of
the 90s when you when you built that
farm system because that it was a quick
fix with a lot of these guys that you
brought in who were over 30 years of age
and you're paying them a lot of money
are the yankees going back to what made
them successful in the 90s i think that
that that's the the game plan I don't
know if they'll they'll have a shift in
it if things don't work out but I still
think you know that they've got guys in
the system they think it's going to be
very good you know Frasier or one of the
kids that came over in a trade it's
supposed to be very well justice
Sheffield a pitcher so they think
they've got the talent down there but I
think that what's going to happen Dan is
that after next year when you lose the
da rod contract the final part of the
a-rod contract and then you you lose the
CC Sabathia spending money as well and
the 2018 free agent class is the big
free agent class I think that what
they'll see is they'll see exactly next
year what they have with the kids and if
the kids could win on their own well
that's even better for the organization
then you've got another core four or
five but if they need supplementing
that's when that the payroll is going to
have a lot of loosening after that you
know a-rod contract in the OCC contract
that frees up 50 million right there and
then they could dive in again you think
a rod's number will be retired my gut
feeling is no but I wouldn't swear to it
there's certainly been a fall in the
relationship with the organization is
going to work for the next year he's
done everything right you know he's
invented himself for the third time and
this time it seems like it it stuck and
I think there's a good relationship
between he and Hal Steinbrenner and how
star murders the guys got to make that
decision first and foremost again my
guess would be no but I never if you
asked me two years ago Dan would they
ever honor him and give him a ceremony I
would say no there's absolutely no way
so things change things change because
this is a guy who was ready to sue
baseball and to the Yankee doctor and
you know they had a thunder infused you
know ceremony in his last game there so
who can figure out any time final
question which bothers Yankee fans more
when the Red Sox play well or the Mets
play well I think probably the Red Sox
just from historical perspective but
doing a radio show in New York Met fans
really do jump Yankee fans when when the
Mets are playing well so it probably is
in their face more but I believe that
the Red Sox winning probably bother some
more thank you Michael we appreciate it
you got any time Dan hope you're well
thank you Mike Michael Kay the Yankee
broadcaster the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience